vamos a intentar multiplicar 6 por 37 y
te voy a mostrar una manera de hacer
esto aunque en futuros vídeos te voy a
mostrar que hay más maneras de
multiplicar aunque en futuros vídeos
ahora aquí voy a usar la llamada forma
estándar y consiste en tomar el número
mayor no importa el orden 6 por 37 es lo
mismo que 37 por 6 ajá no importa el
orden en que multiplique es a mí lo que
me gusta hacer es tomar el número mayor
el 37 en este caso y lo escribo aquí
arriba el 37 y el número menor de los
dos sería el 6 lo voy a poner aquí abajo
escrito en el lugar correcto ajá 6 es de
un dígito entonces lo pongo en el lugar
de las unidades aquí va al 6 entonces 37
por 6 es simple notación están ajá lo
que haremos es multiplicar dígito por
dígito el 6 va a multiplicar a cada uno
de los dígitos en el número 37 entonces
6 por 7 y 6 por 3
ok hagamos esto común
primero vamos a empezar con el 6 por 7 a
6 por 7 si lo recuerdas tu tablas de
multiplicación si lo recuerdas es igual
a 42 6 por 7 es igual a 42 pero pero el
42 lo vamos a poner así nada más no no
no no no vamos a poner el 2 aquí en el
lugar de las de las unidades y llevamos
4 cierto entonces el 4 lo voy a poner
aquí en el lugar de las decenas pero
arriba y ahora 6 por 3 sigue 6 por 3 eso
es igual a 18 ajá 6 por 3 es igual a 18
pero no voy a escribir el 18 así nada
más tenemos el 4 llevamos 4 entonces 6
por 3 es igual a 18 4 debemos sumar ese
4 6 por 3 es igual a 18 + 4 es igual a
22 entonces pongo el 22 aquí y por lo
tanto 37 por 6 es igual a 222 y
terminamos terminamos espero verte en el
próximo vídeo